can we start with the numbers please how
many people
are do we know are infected by omicron
and how many are being hospitalized at
this moment
so what we know
hence the concern is that one third of
infections now in london are omicron
we think
that obviously the reported tests
uh are indicating about sixteen hundred
cases but of course the number of
infections in the community would be a
multiple of that up to 10 times
that we know that it
is highly infectious so the doubling
rate is between two and three days
so uh very quickly
omicron uh will be
get
be the dominant uh variant in the united
kingdom and probably the rest of the
world we've seen this movie before we
saw it with kent variant then of course
delta uh one of the obviously advantages
we have is we've got a very large
capacity for testing and of course
genome sequencing hence why we know so
much we also know
um and i can confirm to you this morning
that there are cases in hospital
with omicron we've been able to
uh
test people who are in hospital over the
past two weeks
and so there is a lag
to hospitalization but the risk of a
highly infectious variant even if it
were
as many people uh quite rightly uh think
because some of the data from south
africa suggesting that it is less uh
severe
even if that is true well if you get to
one million infections because you know
you understand exponential growth
so if you know
by the end of the month you're at a
million with three days later you're at
two million
and if it's
half as severe as delta let's say only
one percent end up with serious
infection and hospitalization that's
still ten thousand people still a big
number it's a huge number you were the
vaccines minister and the government uh
to be honest has
played a great deal on your success on
the rollout and pinned its strategy
entirely on the successful vaccine what
do we know
about the impact of the vaccines
uh first second
and booster job on omicron so you're
absolutely right we've answered the
first question is it more infectious yes
the second question do the vaccines work
well we know now
and some data was published over the
last uh
48 hours
that
two doses of either fisa or isogenic are
not enough they only protect to about
thirty percent assad even less than that
but a booster does raise that protection
back up to where we were when we got to
equilibrium
between vaccine efficacy and delta
and we need to get back to that so this
is going to be a national endeavor we
need to vaccinate with a third jab the
booster jab so important all those
people who become eligible all adults
because it is now a race
between the booster and that protection
and the omicron variant well you've
already said made the point exponential
growth
is
can be astonishing
what are you going to do
to boost the
spread of the the the booster jab as it
were we can't presumably carry on with
the same uh process as we had before we
discovered omicron that's that the the
administration of boosters is going to
have to be accelerated pretty
dramatically what's a plan
so there is absolutely uh a plan and the
premise will be saying more on this um
you will know that the nhs is already
making preparations from monday
for the
30s uh the 30 year olds to be able to
come forward uh after their second job
after you know 90 days so three months
after your second job to get your
booster um we are mobilizing um
the um the the whole team the um uh
frontline we have gps uh community
pharmacies uh military um across the
board volunteers we're asking people to
come forward and volunteer uh you can go
on and uh join the volunteering
army on the national volunteering
service website it's really important
this is a race i genuinely say you can
you can increase the number of people
who are putting uh
jabs in on but what are you doing about
providing more access essentially you
move up to whatever it is 16 million or
something like that in the boosted
presumably you've got to get
into the 30 millions of 40 millions
very very fast yeah so we're over 20
million already um
and you're absolutely right it is now
a race to get
all adults who are eligible
for their boosted jabs to be boosted as
quickly as possible and the prime
minister will be saying more about this
uh later today all right look um the
other side of this is what the prime
minister's been saying that you are
imposing restrictions in order to slow
the spread and give us time
on tuesday the deputy prime minister was
saying that there were no
uh further coronavirus restrictions
required
beyond what you'd said last weekend and
the former prime minister theresa may
was cheered by torrey mps when she said
we've got to learn to live with covet
now within 24 hours situations
turn completely and there are going to
be new restrictions first of all what is
it that happened in that 24 hours so let
me just be clear um as patrick valance
said at the press conference we are
transitioning this virus from pandemic
to endemic but there are
you know big bumps in the road and this
is a big bump a huge bump in the road in
the sense that we now have a a variant
that is so infectious
that it will um dominate and of course
exponentially grow so back to what we're
talking about so let's do a mathematical
exercise for a second
right you get to a million um infections
by say end of december right
one percent is 10 000 severe infections
that could be in hospital three days
later it's two million right three days
later it's four million right three days
beyond that it's eight million right
that is the the risk that even if it's
milder say by 50
milder than delta
the numbers are huge it's a small
percentage of a very large population
that is the big difference um so the
reason we're taking these proportionate
i think uh precautionary measures uh the
most significant of is by the way that
scientists
tell us is the work from home
that will have the greatest impact on
slowing down omicron
so hence why we've had to take these
measures i think they are proportionate
they're precautionary the really
important thing is for the whole nation
this is going to be a national endeavor
uh trevor right a national endeavor to
to
boost the nation as quickly as possible
so that we control omicron and bring
back that equilibrium that we had with
the virus as we continue to protect the
economy and of course on that journey
towards um endemic from pandemic status
is the move to vaccinate primary school
children part of this
race against uh the spread of omicron so
there's no plan at the moment um to
vaccinate primary schools for the reason
that the joint committee on vaccination
immunization is still looking at the uh
evidence as to what level of protection
that would offer those children of
course
we vaccinate the
12 to 15 year olds at pace it's great to
see you know at school in east london
the other day doing uh
the pupils but also managed to do some
of the teachers and parents who hadn't
even had their first uh or second jab uh
really good we're seeing it all over you
know home park in plymouth doing staying
up to 2 a.m vaccinating people so the
important thing is to boost the most
vulnerable that is absolutely the
priority but but surely the important
thing is all the the most important
thing given what you said about the
terrifying spread and all the rest of it
is to stop the spread of the infection
and sage scientists have warned that the
children were the drivers of adult
infection in the summer wave last year
so surely we need to do something about
that so really excellent question which
is why we obviously
begun as soon as we had permission from
the jcvi to vaccinate 12 15 year olds
because you saw a spike in
secondary schools on that
the if you think about exponential
growth which you and i just talked about
this is so infectious
the best way to slow it down is
to keep
you know people working from home for
example keep adults apart
but at the same time is just protecting
the economy hence why it's proportionate
we've tried to do everything in these
new measures to keep the economy open
keep it running protect businesses
because
that also does you know a lot of harm to
people's health mental health as well as
physical health
the important thing is you want to
protect the most vulnerable because you
know that ultimately even if it's less
severe it will put the most vulnerable
okay but surely uh one other thing that
you ought to be thinking about here is
mandatory vaccination
i don't agree with that and i tell you
for why um we have very high levels of
vaccine positivity in the uk probably
highest in the world
all the data suggests that whether it's
the ons or other surveys you know
90 plus percent of all adults say
they've looked at the information
they're protecting themselves protecting
their communities protecting their loved
ones um so to
now play into the hands of the
anti-vaxxers uh by the way i understand
people who are hesitant and it's right
that we focus and give them information
but the anti-vaxxers will will say ah
you see that's why they're they're
they're now doing this stuff actually
the right thing to do is share
information
and okay have this national endeavor now
to really protect it is a race trevor
and we've got to now drive hard for the
next couple of weeks to protect the most
vulnerable all right well look the um
success of that national endeavor
depends
to a large extent on the leadership of
the government so let's talk about
leadership
18 months ago dominic cummings uh
barnard castle
12 months ago prime minister's aides uh
partying and prime minister himself
by the way who knows how many christmas
parties one two three prime minister
himself hosting a quiz night
everybody's breaking the rules that you
set for the rest of us so let me repeat
what i said to one of your cabinet
colleagues earlier on this year
um
why
when you tell us to show restraint
to be part of this national endeavor
should we pay the blindest bit of
attention to you guys
so
the first say on that is that actually
the nation has uh been brilliant at
following the guidelines that was before
they knew what you guys had been up to
all the time even yesterday people were
queuing up at vaccination sites walking
sites or booking uh their
booster jab that's a great thing and i
am you know grateful to to people doing
that and we thank them for that
on parties the cabinet secretary has an
investigation and his investigation can
take him anywhere to look at all parties
i have to say to you you just mentioned
the quiz night and that picture today
what do we see in that picture we see a
prime minister on a virtual uh quiz
night for 10 to 15 minutes to thank his
staff who by the way had no choice but
to come in
every single day let me just finish let
me just finish this point right sitting
in his office with the two people who
are closest working with him no alcohol
on the table not drinking right on a
zoom call or a team's call on virtual
call respecting the the lockdown rules
many people would have had similar zoom
quiz nights around the country yeah and
they would have been nicked for it if i
had done it no if i had done it hold on
i would be in monster trouble but
because you went on a virginia to do it
because you went on a virtual uh he was
sitting next to two people within social
distance they are in his office they
work with him and that was the point was
that no hold on a second when you when
all i'm saying to you is the cabinet
secretary is going to investigate
everything but that picture i'm in many
ways i've had emails from constituents
because the hype around parties that was
going on in the last week and the week
before right made it sound sort of
completely different and actually i
think people will look at that picture
today and the daily mirror has been
leading the way on this and we'll think
hold on a second he's on a virtual call
no alcohol that's not thanking his staff
for ten minutes before he goes back to
work
is that really let's not get too stuck
on the one photograph let us remember
how this issue started over the last two
weeks it started
with the allegation that there were
parties and several days
of the prime minister and other
government spokespeople saying oh no
there were no parties
that's the problem isn't it it's not
that oh something might have happened
that could have happened in any office
it was that we
when when the government was asked did
this happen
we were told point blank they didn't
happen until you had to admit they did
have in your own department
you you fessed up straight away so let
me let me talk about my department and
then talk about
your your question on your question the
prime minister said to the best of his
knowledge um there were no parties
he didn't attend any parties
he also said that the rules were
followed and you saw that in the picture
today it's a virtual zoom
call um not you know anything else and i
think the nation will understand that
now because the hype around it was these
parties you know where people were were
mixing and and lots of drinks was were
flowing um is not there as far as my
department what are you saying the hype
around it are you saying they didn't no
i'm just saying you're not coming in
you're telling me i'm not i am not i'm
saying that the cabinet secretary will
investigate all those allegations he can
go anywhere with his investigation and
that will happen he'll report
rapidly on this as far as my department
when i found out um uh that there was a
gathering uh where people came together
in the canteen who'd been working in the
office because they couldn't work from
home where the previous secretary of
state wanted to thank them then we
apologize because actually upon
reflection in hindsight it shouldn't
have happened
but it's the right thing to do is to
come out and say look this is what
happened people were working at their
desk they brought their own uh drinking
again but we're sitting at their desk
but then it was felt it's better to go
to the canteen to maintain
self-distancing to thank them this is
the hallway
this is exactly my point you did that
by contrast to your boss
and my question to you really i mean
we've known each other for some time
my question to you is
do you feel any sense of shame that you
have to sit at a cabinet table with
people who seem willing to say anything
and do anything
other than to admit the truth as you did
within 24 hours so the
again i'm going to repeat the cabinet
secretary will look at any allegation
his investigator can go anywhere and
he'll report back and then i will come
back on this program and be answerable
for that report but let's step back a
second right i feel very proud that this
prime minister actually set up the
vaccines task force bought 400 million
plus vaccines for the nation we've got
enough supply for the booster which we
now know and if you hadn't made a
decision to spend the money on the
additional fisa
doses we would not have the booster
campaign today but let's i feel very
proud we're the first country to open up
and to maintain that opening of the
economy kiyosama wanted us not to open
the economy imagine the damage that
would have died to people's lives i'm
going to let you say all of that but
let's let's be honest with each other
all of that may be true
but
he has essentially
squandered that credit
because now
when he asks people to do things the
doubt about whether we can trust his
word is immense surely even you must
admit this is not irrespective of the
politics of it and all that this is
getting in the way of tackling that
terrifying threat that you've described
earlier in this interview we need to
move fast and every day the people
cannot trust the prime minister
is costing lives you must see that
well
as i was saying to you earlier actually
if you look at the evidence people have
been very good at understanding how to
protect themselves their family and
their community they've been very good
at following the rules hence why we were
able to reopen the economy and do it so
successfully we're now asking them again
to be cautious to be careful um
proportionately and to try and and to
race towards the booster well to to to
trust their government that managed to
deliver the most successful vaccination
program in history and of course reopen
the economy so rapidly and by the way
spend 407 billion protecting jobs and
livelihoods all right one last let me
give this one last go they sent you out
this morning with a brief frankly to
defend the indefensible um
is it time to admit the prime minister
who you've supported all along uh
in i think the most
honest and open way is it time to admit
that
you supported him in part because he's
an election winner but he's now becoming
a liability i don't agree with that i
work very closely
with boris johnson i worked with him
when i was business and industry
minister with the vaccines task force
and then when he asked me to do the
vaccination deployment program he works
literally all hours to make sure we get
through this pandemic
the number of decisions i've seen him
make including making sure we had enough
vaccine making sure we have this the
fastest vaccine deployment program and
he will make sure again that the booster
campaign is going to be a national
endeavor he's he is doing a serious job
at a serious time for the nation and
actually
if you look at the hype that's been
going on for two weeks around parties
i'd reverse the question and say you
know let's are the media you said
earlier before we went on air you know
little things keep us busy in the media
right
are you really getting the right balance
here all right in terms of in terms of
you know omicron is such an important
variance
versus versus talking about a zoom call
um where he's where he was motivating
his team so we had to work every day
without having you know they can't have
the ability to work from hope i've been
counting we spent the first 50 or 60 of
this interview talking about omicron you
did so we're not i'm not burying you
with trivia look
let's deal with something that could be
real
you could be back in here next sunday
after a conservative defeat
in the by-election at north shropshire
are you still going to be telling me in
that situation that boris johnson is the
right leader in north shropshire no fuel
after he loses well neil shastri hurst
is a doctor who's been vaccinating
people himself
he is an
incredible asset
to uh the the political um uh landscape
in the united kingdom and i am confident
that the people of north shropshire will
see that and will actually support neil
shastrihurst on thursday and he'll be
returned as our next time
and if he doesn't i will be back on your
program but i am confident that actually
when you look at what neil hearst has
done in his life okay he is an excellent
member of parliament for north
shropshire and boris johnson still be
boris johnson leader will will be
focusing on that national endeavor to
boost the nation it's a race against
time